Traduttore: Irene Andreoni
Revisore: SILVIA ALLONE
Sessanta milioni e cinquecentomila
sono i cittadini italiani.
Di questi, quattro milioni e mezzo
hanno una disabilità certificata.
Dico certificata perché, diciamolo,
ognuno di noi ha qualcosa che non sa fare,
ognuno di noi è uscito
con un difetto di fabbrica.
Ad esempio, alzi la mano
chi almeno una volta
non ha saputo azzeccare
i tempi di cottura della pasta.
(Risate)
Eh, anche io, ma io non cucino, quindi -
Oppure quanti di noi, al supermercato,
bussano sui cocomeri
facendo finta di sapere
se siano maturi oppure no?
Oppure, al casello dell'autostrada
non arriviamo al biglietto,
e li vedi lì che si chinano,
che sembro io quando cerco
di prendere una gioia nella mia vita.
(Risate)
Poi, strizzare il dentifricio
in mezzo al tubetto e non dal fondo
è una piccola disabilità.
Oppure non saper nemmeno aprire una latta
con i sottoli senza l'apriscatole.
Spezzare gli spaghetti.
O lasciare le chiavi della macchina
dentro la macchina,
o lavare la macchina
poco prima che scoppi un temporale.
Poi c'è questa.
Fare la cacca senza essersi accorti
che manca la carta igienica.
Non saper parcheggiare nemmeno una Smart.
Dare indicazioni sbagliate.
Io ho sempre l'ansia:
chissà se li hanno ritrovati,
tutti quelli a cui ho dato indicazioni.
(Risate)
E poi ci sono le disabilità
secondo un genere:
quelle solo dei maschietti,
e quelle solo delle femminucce.
Ad esempio, noi uomini
non sappiamo mai trovare le cose
nella borsa delle donne.
Oppure ci dimentichiamo gli anniversari:
quello di matrimonio,
di fidanzamento, del primo bacio -
perché lei vuole sapere
anche quello del primo bacio.
O facciamo la pipì ogni tanto fuori.
O meglio: voi, io no
perché io la fo seduto.
Tiè, almeno una evitiamola.
Le donne: essere bionde e intelligenti
e quindi sorbirsi il luogo comune
sulle bionde e stupide.
Saper guidare la macchina,
e quindi sorbirsi il luogo comune sulle
"donne al volante, pericolo costante".
Poi ci sono le disabilità invisibili:
quelle, cioè, che da fuori non vedi,
ma che sono comunque importanti.
Ad esempio, abitare
in Molise e non esistere.
Oppure essere ultimi
nella classifica di Paolo Fox.
(Risate)
Allora, tornando a noi,
quattro milioni e mezzo di disabili:
va da sé che sono 56 milioni
i cittadini cosiddetti "normodotati".
Che vuol dire?
Vuol dire che la disabilità
in qualche modo,
purtroppo o per fortuna,
è un argomento che riguarda la minoranza
della minoranza degli italiani.
E tutto ciò che non
conosciamo ci spaventa,
tutto ciò che non appartiene a noi
tendiamo un po' ad allontanarlo.
Ecco perché dobbiamo parlarne,
e dobbiamo anche stimolare empatia
affinché il nostro ego si metta da parte
e possiamo così metterci
nei panni degli altri,
e arricchirci conoscendo qualcosa
che prima non avevamo vissuto.
Ma come possiamo farlo?
Ad esempio, con l'amore.
"Sono single per forza,
non piglio l'autobus":
questo è un articolo
che io scrissi nel 2014.
Era un appello alla politica
un po' provocatorio,
dove dicevo: fatemi prendere il treno,
non perché sia un mio diritto,
ma perché voglio innamorarmi
su un autobus, su un treno,
incontrando la ragazza dei miei sogni
come in un film romantico
con Richard Gere e Julia Roberts.
(Risate)
Eh, che ridete?
Guardate che se prendete Richard Gere,
e lo mettete in carrozzina,
siamo due gocce d'acqua, eh.
Non è che ci sia tutta questa differenza.
(Applausi)
L'articolo fu condiviso
in tutta Italia, e anche oltre.
Questo, ad esempio,
è un articolo della BBC
che, insomma, gli sembrava strano
che un ragazzo fosse costretto
a lanciare una campagna
per una cosa che per loro era naturale.
E mi ricordo benissimo
l'emozione di quei giorni,
la prima telefonata a mia nonna:
"Nonna, mi ha intervistato la BBC!"
"Bravo, Ninin, bravo!"
Oppure: "Nonna, domani
mi intervista Al Jazeera!"
"Oh mamma, stai attento!"
Mi aveva già visto sequestrato
in Medio Oriente,
come finale tragico di questa avventura:
dico finale perché mia mamma col cavolo
che avrebbe pagato il riscatto.
(Risate)
E tutto questo per dire che ognuno di noi,
a partire da quando si alza la mattina,
ha un grande potere:
quello di poter essere
un piccolo ingranaggio
nel motore del cambiamento culturale.
Possiamo, attraverso quello che facciamo,
quello che diciamo, ogni giorno,
attraverso quello che siamo,
influenzare gli altri
per provare a rompere quei pregiudizi
e quegli stereotipi.
Pregiudizi e stereotipi
che troviamo veramente ovunque,
oggi come 400 anni fa.
Un po' come i Terrapiattisti.
Ecco, per esempio una volta
ero al ristorante con la mia famiglia,
si avvicina la cameriera
e, senza nemmeno guardarmi,
dice al mio babbo,
indicandomi con la testa:
"Il coltello, il coltello lo usa?"
E mio babbo le disse:
"Sì, soprattutto se si arrabbia."
(Risate)
Inutile dirvi che la cameriera
mi mise forchetta, coltello,
bicchiere del vino,
anche quello dello spumante
come i grandi, insomma, come gli adulti.
Peccato che non sapeva che sono nato
con una grave disabilità dalla nascita,
cioè sono astemio.
(Risate)
E quindi la cena finì più o meno così.
Oppure, quando entro in un negozio,
il commesso o la commessa
non si rivolge mai a me in carrozzina,
ma all'accompagnatore:
"Salve, mi dica..."
Poi, quando c'è da chiedere i soldi,
li chiede sempre a quello giusto, cioè io.
Ma, diciamoci la verità,
ognuno di noi è vittima di pregiudizi.
Anche un po' in maniera inconsapevole,
non per cattiveria.
Ogni tanto qualche pregiudizio
lo abbiamo avuto tutti.
Un esempio chiaro sono loro: le mie nonne.
Ecco, io sono nato in una famiglia
con un cugino, Fabio,
di sette anni più grande,
alto due metri, sportivo, bello,
con questa barbetta brizzolata,
affascinante.
Ecco, immaginatevi i pranzi
e le cene con i parenti:
io ogni volta seduto accanto a lui.
Arriva il momento della classica domanda,
la nonna a lui:
"Allora, la fidanzatina?"
Poi era il mio turno.
"Allora, la scuola?"
(Risate)
Già da piccolo, avevo capito
che qualcosa non andava:
poi, crescendo,
le cose non sono migliorate.
Oggi a lui chiedono:
"Allora, quando ti sposi?"
E a me: "Allora, quando ti laurei?"
Oppure, dopo mangiato
arriva il momento dei regali.
E le nonne non ti fanno il regalo,
ti fanno la busta.
E le vedi lì avvicinarsi, come un pusher
e la passano sottobanco.
E a lui la mia nonna diceva sempre:
"Con questi ci porti a cena
la fidanzatina."
E a me diceva sempre: "Tieni,
con questi ti ci compri la merenda.
(Risate)
Fortunatamente,
aver scritto il mio ultimo libro
dove parlo anche
delle mie relazioni sentimentali
le ha fatto capire che il suo bambino
non è più un bambino.
E allora, ad esempio, la prima festa
dopo la pubblicazione del libro
me la ricorderò sempre: era Pasqua.
Arrivò mia nonna, non aveva la busta,
aveva i soldi in mano,
ce li mise in tasca a tutti e due,
stette zitta, ci disse solamente:
"Auguri."
E quello è stato il regalo più bello
che potessi ricevere.
E allora, tutto questo per dire due cose,
su questo palco
volevo portare due messaggi.
Il primo è che ognuno di noi
ha una disabilità;
ma soprattutto, la disabilità
non esisterebbe
se dessimo, a tutti, gli strumenti
per poter fare quello che fanno gli altri.
Il secondo messaggio dice
che ognuno di noi,
così come ha delle disabilità,
ha anche delle abilità.
Può mettersi a disposizione
degli altri, della collettività,
come una risorsa vera e propria
per migliorare questo Paese.
Perché dobbiamo farlo?
Per soldi?
Per successo?
No.
Perché semplicemente, è umanamente giusto
abbattere muri culturali
e costruire ponti.
Grazie.
(Applausi)
Mi dicono che ho ancora tre minuti,
e allora se siete d'accordo
vorrei dire un'ultima cosa.
Sì, perché va bene l'associazionismo,
il volontariato, lavorare per gli altri -
siamo tutti buoni,
però ogni tanto una piccola
soddisfazione personale,
dai, va bene prendersela.
È una piccola rivincita,
quindi se mi date due minuti -
me li date? Posso?
5 Marzo 2019:
il Presidente della Repubblica,
Sergio Mattarella,
mi nomina Cavaliere della Repubblica.
Qui è quando mi dice che sono bravissimo,
qui è quando mi dice che sono bellissimo,
(Risate)
qui è quando mi chiede
se possiamo fare una foto insieme.
(Risate)
Questa foto è rimbalzata
su tutti i giornali.
È diventata il simbolo
di quella mattinata,
e, devo dire, ne sono stato
molto orgoglioso e soddisfatto.
Addirittura, nonostante fossimo a Marzo,
qualche giornalista
l'ha addirittura "promossa",
nominata come foto dell'anno.
Peccato che, dopo poche settimane,
sia uscita questa.
(Risate)
(Applausi)
Tutta la visibilità, tutto il successo,
tutta la bellezza della cerimonia,
spazzata via da un buco nero.
Che io ci ho anche provato a dire:
"Non è una foto, è una ricostruzione
al computer, finta!" - ma niente.
La foto del buco nero.
Allora, c'è una terza cosa
che noi stasera ci siamo ricordati:
che per quanto alto tu voglia essere,
per quanto grande tu voglia costruire
il piedistallo su cui metterti,
tanto ci sarà sempre qualcuno che arriverà
e risucchierà, come un buco nero,
(Risate)
tutto il successo e i riflettori
puntati su di te.
E allora, tanto vale,
nonostante queste spalle strette
e la cartella clinica di un settantenne
che ha guardato troppi cantieri,
se ce la fo io figuratevi voi,
tanto vale mettersi in gioco
per provare a costruire
qualcosa di buono per tutti.
(Applausi)